who in the cast would make the best
astronaut and who instantly
would just like flat out flunk out of
the program
you would flunk out oh i'd be the best
astronaut
sakes now i know what you're thinking i
know what's your answer
yes okay you were my vote for best
astronaut
so kyle why would you why would you
naturally be a great astronaut
because uh you know i've just got that
thing you know that
astronaut kind of thing
you know you saw that thing does take
you far in space
yes i know how to sit in a chair i know
how to slide
you know slide the the little imaginary
bars
and i know how to look and i know what's
going on
i would feel safe totally if i was in
there with you now tiffany would you
make a great astronaut what do you think
would you pass
with flying colors what do you think no
i would not make a great attitude
i mean even when i was doing research
before we began and just reading about
the training that they go through
it's so intense um
you know people have lost their hearing
in the process i mean it's there's a lot
that can happen to you
i space isn't worth all that to me
personally so
i would not be
you're like i would like to stay here so
if you were told that
you were going on a mission to space
what would be the one thing that you
would take with you and why i mean let's
get you thinking this movie about all
those things but personal relationships
and
even just things that you would have
with you so what or who would you take
with you tiffany we'll start with you
oh who would i take my husband i'd take
my husband i thought if it was just an
object that's a little harder but
if it's a person my husband okay
kyle well of course i'm going to say my
wife
you have to okay
what's the thing then do you both have a
thing that you would take
a dog is that a thing no i take my dog
well it's a thing well i take my dog too
these animals in space i love it
all right let's talk about um george is
a director
does he have tricks on set to get the
best performance out of his
out of his stars what can you say about
this process and and working with
georgian
sort of what was he like as a director
with you personally both of you
um i mean i think the trick is just
being a great person like he's just a
great leader i don't think there's
i mean maybe inside his head he's
tricking us and i just have no idea
but um he creates a vibe on set
that makes everyone want to do their
best work
um it makes you okay with waking up
before the sun comes up to go to work
and
leaving when the sun goes down um
because
he makes it a fun environment he just
gets the best people together and and
lets you have a good time so
he's he's really great nice kyle how
about you what did
what was your experience like i've
worked with him
twice as well twice as an actor and
as a director actually but um uh
the same elements with the same elements
that that tiffany
was just speaking about and uh um
you know i don't have to repeat him you
can look at you can look at all the work
that he's done
um and uh and see that he knows what
he's doing and he's
he's he's you know he's very
knowledgeable and he's uh
very good at what he does and and he he
works with people
and uh it's i found it an
awful lot of fun both times i've worked
with them i feel very very fortunate
nice and lastly i'll get in trouble if i
don't ask this friday night lights would
you do
a prequel based on your character coach
taylor
shoot yeah
okay well that's something i feel like
that's something for fans right
sure you aren't giving me
nothing i ain't got nothing
i just got back from space with the one
i was out
and there's a pandemic all of a sudden
give me a break
all right fair enough thank you so much
you too really appreciate
it have a really nice night have a happy
and full
uh new year's holiday and all that
thank you appreciate that you too both
of you be well
you